hey y'all it's center couch here and
this tight dude is a video i'm be
concluding my teddy bear series with
ggplot2
so ggplot2 is probably the most famous r
package i would say
um among the data science community
because it's all about
charts and plots
and gg spot 2 or ggpot i really
revolutionized how people kind of
approach with creating charts
specifically it's called the the grammar
of graphics
and it's kind of this entire system of
how to um plot data visualizations
programmatically and
it's kind of like uh it was kind of it
was kind of based off of the entire um
tidy verse uh the foundation of the
titan verse where we're always trying to
create like tidy
um equivalents
so it matches really well
um
for this video i'm probably just going
to go over some of the basic
um components of ggplot2 specifically
like the intuition that goes into it i'm
going to try to not use any
of the other tidy verse packages
specifically like d plier and tidy are
because i already have some videos on
that
but i really want to kind of go over the
intuition of a gdp plot and also show
you know maybe some common things you
would want to use
um
when working with the package so i'm
going to open up a uh our markdown
i'll call this ggplot2
actually i think we'll just do
plot two
um
and we'll just load in the tidy verse
okay
so
teddyverse has actually um some included
data sets and we're just going to use
those as examples for
um creating some plots using ggplot
so the first data set is the iris data
set
um showing kind of some characteristics
of a flower species um with the actual
species so the first thing you want to
do when creating a chart using ggplot is
you want to call the ggplot function
so gg plot
and this is
essentially the foundation
of any plot you want to make in
the gdp plot framework so
with ggplot we have our data
and mapping
commands so
with data where you want to kind of pass
in our data set so data equals iris
and then our mapping is
what we want to actually plot out
the mapping and then you say aes which
is the aesthetic
um and then you can have
multiple argument arguments
um in this case we have like x
so we can say x equals uh simple.lang
so right there that's kind of your basic
um commands right so we have that
and right now we have a ggplot
plot
um you know using the x and y axis
as our points
um and if you notice when we have our we
specify the column i'm in iris um it's
able to kind of call from that data
frame that we specified in the ggplot
object so ggplot has we've created like
a gdpr object using the iris data set so
then we can start using um columns or
features from that data set um inside of
this gt plots object
um one thing that's kind of interesting
about gdpr is we're essentially stacking
uh layers to the plot so right now we we
kind of have a blank canvas it's showing
you know a grid with our specified uh
components that we want to plot out but
we actually want to like kind of call
what do we actually want to plot in this
case you know what i'm thinking is like
probably just a basic scatter plot so
i'd like to have some points on it um to
kind of maybe show like some type of
correlation or whatever
so when we have our ggpod object
we want to add the plus sign so plus
and then what we can do is our geom
and our gm is basically
all the types of like
plotting things we can do in a gt plot
object as you can see um there's
actually a decent amount of things
but if we do geom and then if we type in
point
uh
and execute it we can see we now have a
nice little scatter plot comparing the
width and length of a sepal on for a
species
cool so that's probably like our first
plot we would ever make when kind of
learning ggplot
but um there's a few other things that
we can kind of look into so let's try to
do that
i'm going to copy this ggplot object and
kind of explain a little bit more things
in detail about um things that we kind
of don't need to use so
um when we're calling ggplot um
tidyverse the gdp in general are smart
enough to understand
um what things are what so instead of
calling data equals iris we can just
call iris
mapping equals aesthetic uh we don't
have to type all that out we can just
type in aesthetic and we still get the
same ggplot object
so one of the things that we probably
want to look at is hey uh we want to
plot out you know maybe a comparison
between the sepal length and width um
and maybe we want to see the differences
of it uh through its species
so since we have a faster or essentially
a non-numeric value we can give it a
color
and there's a lot of ways we can do this
okay so with ggplot we can pass it in to
the point
or we can pass into the actual g g plot
object
and they do base uh they do similar
things except one is a little bit more
explicit
so
anything you want to pass into a ggpod
object so right here um
will basically be passed into any other
um like stacked um layer so if you pass
in the color as species it'll be passed
into the gm point so anything
all the points will be corresponding to
the color while also corresponding to
the x value and y value so right here
we since we want to specify something
that's specific to our data set uh we
always want to put it inside of the aes
or aesthetic so if i say color is equal
to
species
we can see now that these points are
corresponding to these species of flower
but if we wanted to do something
more specific like like put it in gm
points we need to always specify if
we're going to be referencing the data
set an aes or aesthetic so if we do that
we can see we have the same thing
that being said
um
let me see that there and i'm gonna
copy paste this
uh color
equal to species
let's say same thing but do slightly
different things
right so let's show an example of why
they're slightly different
so in this case
we have
um
we have these two plots
and maybe instead of um having
uh
so maybe we want to actually kind of
explore some relationships right we have
our scatter plots but maybe we want to
have like some some
straight lines going through it to show
kind of the only relationship for each
group
okay
so in this case what we can do
is i'll actually start building a
plot from scratch
so we'll add a gm
point and we'll all actually add in too
is a gm
uh smooth so this is like a smooth line
and with gm smooth we have different
commands so right now i think i'll use
like a lowest
all right
in this case we probably want a method
and our method we can use like uh glms
gams stuff like that in this case we'll
just do a glm
right and we can see how it's straight
so this is our first plot um that we
want to kind of start tweaking in this
case
we want to add in the color equal
species so color equals
species
right and we can see that
it is essentially mapping to one the the
points of the scatter plot with the
color of the species and also the um
linear they'll
the smooth lines that are going through
by each species
so what would happen
if we specify
oracle species
but with gm point
right
we can see now if we compare this first
plot to the second one we see that it
colors this the points
but our gm smooth or our linear line
goes through it as if there's no types
of groupings
okay
um so
an example of how
um
specif of of how specifying
color
impacts um the plot
right and
in this case we might think like
well i want to plot out you know this
plot right here but maybe i don't really
want
um
you know the colors to be right here
um i can just like always specify that
we want to kind of be plotting on like a
group level effect from our factors
um
which
in this case what we can do is we can
specify
in our entire ggbot object which is kind
of like the global variables um object
we can say group oops
you can say group
equal to species
and what that does is it'll basically
specify everything as a group for the
species and then we can start adding
whatever we want so in this case we
right here we can see how the points are
uh corresponding to the color of this or
the the type of species for the color
we can also do that for the
line
so right here they're all black but the
lines are
are are corresponding by species
so you can see how this is actually um
kind of interesting and that you know it
could be potentially useful if you you
know you want to like highlight
something or you want to do some
tweaking so there are multiple ways to
plot things and they do
essentially the same thing
but they come with different types of
quirks
okay
so i think that's kind of a nice little
overview of like how you use color and
groups um specifically when you're
you're plotting out factors
oops so um we'll actually go into um
more of like some typical plots you
would expect so
in this case we'll just say data equals
iris
all right
so we've gone over the scatter plot
right here um one thing we can do is
like a gm uh bar i think
and for me personally i
don't use
um
i don't use um gm bar
um there's some weird there's some
quirks with gm bar and let's say gm
uh
column
um gm bar
if you want to create a typical bar plot
uh gm bar
will just take in a list of like
categories and they'll do the
computation um in itself
and that can be uh that can be nice when
we do like a quick plot but sometimes
you know you want to um plot say let's
do a um
uh let's actually let's do a uh let's
use the diamond diamonds data set
um in this case we'll just do the i
guess
a cut
maybe
or like no we'll do the color
right
so that's that's nice right there um but
maybe we want to like specify a certain
type of like order or stuff like that so
instead what we can do is we can count
um
diamonds by color
and what we can do is we can like
specify how we want to sort these labels
so um i know i didn't want to kind of go
into a lot of other um uh like data
cleaning like deep wire and tidy art but
i think this is kind of a good example
of
um
uh
changing how
uh
i'm using uh gdpr and deep wire together
so
it
and then what we can do is pass end
right here
color y equals n
and then what we can do with gm column
right so this is a little bit obviously
a little bit more work when you're doing
your um plotting on a bar chart
compared to gm bar
but we have a little bit more um
flexibility with how we want to plot
things out
so i'm right there i think that's kind
of useful um but uh you know you can
always use gm bar too um there's there
is
a decent amount of commands with gm bar
if we go back here into our uh oops
references and we'll get out here
uh references um we can see how we have
all of these things
um when we look up you know bar
and we have um a few things right here
so i'm sure there's like different ways
we can do um orientations and uh stuff
like that
maybe is there a
yeah
so we can see how there's a dif a few
ways we can do it
okay
so one thing i would say that's uh
kind of useful too if we're gonna be
experimenting with more bar charts is
um oftentimes you know we might wanna
count
they they cut and color
and plot those out
so let's say gigi pot
um color equals
oops uh
color and we're just going to plot out a
bar chart
and we'll say color is equal to cut
and do that
right
and right here is kind of an example of
there's a difference between
uh ways that there's different ways to
basically color on a chart
some chart objects
like gm calm will require instead of
using color a fill
so instead of color we have to suicide
fill
right
additionally we might want to say like
hey what if we want to um you know not
have these um this these uh
uh
ohm charts stacked we can also specify
specify the position so if say position
sequel to i think uh dodge
uh they'll be kind of next to each other
which could be useful so
um there might be other positions too
with gm calm
but i personally don't really use um
anything else besides position equals
dodge and even then uh i'll do usually
something else um so let me actually go
right there
um position equals stack is there
anything else
maybe
i don't know i don't i don't know
but you can see that there's different
ways to
um
plot out
a column a column chart or bar chart
and they'll do
slightly different things i personally
think this looks a little bit more
cluttered but again this this could be
useful too
cool
so uh now that we have our basic charts
uh we might want to kind of do a little
bit more complex stuff so if we're
looking if we're creating charts and
kind of looking at
specific specifically like different
groups um so we'll go back to our
um
you know our iris data sets right
here um oftentimes
uh you might want to create multiple
charts
uh so in this case i'll just show you
how to do that um and we'll just
add on to our existing plots and there's
two there's a few different ways how we
can plot out multiple charts so in this
case i want to make you know a chart
comparing simple width and simple length
for each group with a line going through
it okay
so right now we have
all three
all three species in one chart
but it'd be kind of interesting just
kind of separate them out
um
what we can do is we can use facets
wrap
and fast wrap will specify basically how
we want to like
facet our charts or create multiple
charts
um in this case with to call facets you
can use you have to use the tilde sign
tilde and specify um the thing you want
to kind of like uh create a chart by so
in this case since we want to create
like a chart like an individual chart
for each species we do use the tilde and
specify
species
right
and we can see we have three different
charts um you can specify the like the
the rows so n row is equal to like one
it
uh n row is equal to like three i mean
it'll just kind of it'll change the
order so we can kind of have it more
like vertical but um generally i'll just
kind of leave that in auto
now you may notice that
um they're on the same scale
um and deciding what type of scale you
want to do
is depending on your type of analysis so
in this case it's kind of nice to have
it at the same scale because you can see
how these people with a simple length
are in different kind of um
um
you know they're in they kind of vary by
species in a pretty uh
a specific manner um and we can see how
the relationship of it um or the
correlation between um the components
are a little bit different for each
species but
uh
we can only specify how
um the scale of it so if we do scales
the default will be free
i i will be a fixed sorry
the default is fixed so that they have a
fixed scale for each plot
and i think it just uses the existing
original plot without fastening but we
we can also specify three
y
so in this case the y axis can change
for each um species or each facet
but the x axis
uh will stay fixed so you can also
specify free
x
and uh the y axis will be fixed too so
in this case i think that's that's kind
of nice because we can see how like
you know um we have the same range of
sepal length for all the species but we
can see how you know setosa versicolor
virginia virginia color have like on
average oscillate difference
um
um average widths
um and yeah and then lastly we're gonna
say free in general and
that'll have individual scales uh for
each plot
okay
so there's also another one called
facets grid
um facet grid oops plastic grid
is slightly different
so we can specify our rows and our
columns so in this case we can say rows
is equal to
um species
um
if we say rose equals species it'll give
us an error it's because you have to
specify vars as like a variable
um and we can see how for each row for
our plots we have species so instead of
specifying manually you know by like the
number of rows or number of columns uh
we can do facet grid in that case it'll
actually specify like an actual
grid of plots instead of just you know
kind of like
uh an array of plots or i don't know
just a list of plots
um
one thing that's kind of useful um with
facet grid and sometimes i'll use it
more is like if we want to fasten it by
multiple things
so let's see if we can use the uh
the diamonds data sets
um
and we'll just kind of
i don't know
we'll do the price right so
i'll just say gdpot
x equals parrot right
y equals price
uh gm point
so right now we have this
uh oh wait is it is this yeah so we have
that and we might want to pass facet
uh grid
and we'll just fasten grid by like i
guess
i don't know cut and color
does that make sense
sure
so cut
and then columns equals bars
okay and we can see here how we have uh
individual colors and their cuts
uh carrot by price
um so
oops you can see how uh we have kind of
like a a pairwise amount of plots so if
you want to compare
um
the price versus carrot
or
i don't know a d colored i don't know
what d color is like dark color maybe or
um there's probably something that goes
into it that's uh a fair
um
uh fair row or
yeah a fair row or no it's a fair color
sorry yeah fair uh no no
yeah like the cut is fair the color is d
or whatever
uh we can see how um we can see the plot
right
um and then we can also change our
scales
say jeff like free
and we can get a nice little um plot so
we generate like what was it five uh
you know like 35 pots in a matter of
seconds by just adding asset grid
so um one thing to also note is you
don't even have to use fast great if you
want to do
if you want to facet by multiple column
multiple columns or fields you can do
facet
wrap
in this case you have to still um call
tilde but we can also say cut plus
color
scales equals free
and it'll do the same thing but we don't
have those little a nice little grid
you'll kind of do it automatically
uh you see how it's a little bit more um
i'm busy because it'll just kind of
create um a few
i'll just do that
and where is it
um
okay so we have this um as you can see
it's saying like fair d
um
so we have a bunch of plots right here
for me personally i don't think it's as
clean as using facet grid but oftentimes
i'll usually use faster wrap over faster
grids so
if if you want to do a lot of tweaking
you can kind of compare between faster
rapid faster grid
and get slightly different results
cool
um so
i think that's a pretty good spot where
you're kind of showing your general
plots um again
um i don't want to go through every
um type of plot you can create in gdpr
because essentially it's just calling
the command as long you as long as you
have these specific variables so you
know gm line you need an x and a y
variable gm call you know you need a
categorical variable or something like
that um
uh distributions again you need an x
value
um
so again i don't think it's too much
uh
to nest it's not i don't think it's
completely necessary for me to go
through all of them like gm segment you
need you know four variables or four um
points stuff like that um and then for
the geospatial stuff i'll make a
separate video on that because i think
gg5 is a little bit weaker on the
geospatial stuff
okay
but now what i want to do is kind of go
into like the formatting of plots and
formatting of plots is actually kind of
a pain
and it's not because it's very hard
but um it does require actually
like a lot of memorization and a lot of
the
work that goes into it so if you say
ggplot like
uh
like format color or something like that
um you kind of can go down the rabbit
hole
um the best way to look at formatting
is to go on this website um with data
visualizations um they kind of explain
to you a lot of ways to customize plots
from like a
color standpoint and like adding you
know labels and text and stuff like that
so
um i don't if you're kind of approaching
ggpi in general you shouldn't really
think you need to have everything
memorized you know on an interview
they're not going to ask you like how do
you make a chart
like blank with no y and x axis labels
uh that's not going to be something that
they're going to ask you it's way more
about like uh you know
interpreting charts or how do you create
a nice chart or like what's your you
know philosophy on it stuff like that um
so i want to feel too scared about like
oh wow there's a lot of ways you can
format you know a pot
um just i wouldn't really worry about
too much try to you know obviously
retain some of the information but i'm
definitely just kind of look at this
website and i'll post it in the
description um
to actually go over like aesthetic
cleaning but uh with that being said
i'll show you guys a few different
things that are somewhat useful
for plotting out um
for plotting and doing some scale uh x
for do some aesthetic adjustments so in
this case i'll just say color is equal
to price
um
i think this is like a yeah so yep right
here
in this case we might want to like
adjust the color um i don't maybe i
don't want like a blue gradient
um so what we can do is we can add plus
and we can say scale
color
and now we can go into all the different
palettes that we can do
um
so scale color bin is a kind of a bin uh
brewer is i think kind of the uh oops
is
yeah it's something where it's more a
little bit different
um
so it's more i guess you need to do it
with a discrete value
but
um one thing that we can do is like uh i
don't know
fermenter sure
mentor right so we kind of have um some
nice little cutoffs um if we actually
look into the fermenter
guide we can see n a values are gray
the aesthetics is color um stuff like
that
um maybe what what we want to do is
scale like burtis or color
on vertice
which is the common um color palette
you'll see in ggpot i think they even
show it to you as like an example
right here you know it's a nice
separation between all the gradients um
from like dark to light
so that's a common way to have
um
different types of colors um
obviously since we know that there's a
difference between fill and color
whatever you're kind of trying to adjust
you can have to you have to kind of
change scale color too
i'm scale bill for this
so
that's one thing yeah i kind of have to
think about i know when i was starting
out um when i was trying to adjust the
color range of a pot sometimes they
wouldn't change because i misspecified
you know color instead of fill or or
whatever
cool
so
we have this right here i'll just put
this
right there so
custom colors
and then you know what i'll do uh
i'll do a fill too so i'll do uh
i don't know diamonds
we'll count cut
and color
yes and we'll plot this out so x equals
color y equals n bill equals to cut
create a column chart
and i'll just do a chord flip
uh chord flip
so obviously we can do some
transformations uh chord flip is
probably the more popular ones where we
just hope the x and y axis you don't
even have actually you don't have to
actually do this so instead of doing
chord flip we can just
change it to x equals n
and y equals color
right there
so
okay um so we can also do like scale
bill
and then you know maybe a different
one
um
i don't know which one i would do uh
maybe a vertice was it d
or vertice
uh
oops
but yeah so we can
let me
scale up
phil and i don't know maybe we can do
uh
that one or
oh okay you know what i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna go over that that seems like a
pain to kind of go over
but
um so we have this plot
um
and you know we might we might want to
change some things so in this case what
we can do is add plus and say labs
and this is where we want to add you
know some type of annotation so you know
our our title is equal to
you know we can specify a title um so we
say title is equal to and then we have
to do some quotes because we're passing
in a string so like
carrot
um parrot versus price
um so
we do that we have a little title
um
we can also do a subtitle so subtitle
equals like
you know
um
larger carrot
uh
you know a larger carrot
or larger uh stones
are more expensive
right
something super obvious
so yeah we have that
um
uh and then we can also specify you know
our x axis and y axis titles and also
the the fill so in this case we can say
x equals like
you know if we maybe want to say carrot
and then y equals like a price
and then the uh
bill is equal to
or or color
is equal to like
dollars
and you can see how that change it where
we capitalize price carrot and then our
fill is like dollars
um
there's also a few things we can do with
like
um the
things with the uh x and y axis so we
can say scale
y is continuous
um
and there's multiple ways so there's
multiple options with our scaling so if
we say scale like y
uh the scale y band continuous date
daytime log 10 and stuff like that so
you know if we want we could maybe scale
the price by log 10
and now just kind of apply the
transformation to the y axis
and that can be useful
um in this case
uh what we wanted to do is maybe do like
a y continuous
and why would we do that since it kind
of already implicitly is continuous um
and it kind of it'll be smart enough to
do that but what we can add in is like
our our like
um we can add in a few different options
so
um with the scales package
um we can also do um like dollar format
or like i think was it label dollar
or is it dollar
format
uh was it
dollar
okay maybe it's uh
yep yep labels equals uh dollars format
um so that's like the you know y-axis
labels
um and then it'll add in the dollar sign
so you don't have to like manually go in
and stuff like that um i think that's
one thing that i wasn't really taught um
with ggplot is that there's a scales
package that often has a lot of useful
ways to adjust scales you know you can
specify the p-value
kind of clean up some labels that are
common in data science and statistics in
this case i think the most popular ones
that i use is
dollar format
and percent format
um so if you're working with percent so
um we'll go back to
um i will go back to diamonds
and we'll count the uh cut
and color
and maybe we'll do uh you know
and so we'll say
prop
so in this case basically for each
um
i we're kind of specifying the
the proportion of the colors
so in this case
y equals prop fill equals color
right so now it's in a percent format
it's kind of like a percent bar chart
um mo can do this space
scale
why continuous
labels is equal to scales um percent
format
and we have a percent
so
one thing that i would say with like
scale y continuous scale y a scale x
discrete right scale x discrete is that
it can get very confusing very quick so
if we do scale y continuous we can see
that there's name breaks minor breaks
and dot breaks labels limits expand you
know all that stuff um i think it's
common
to kind of be uh apparently or scared of
like oh you know what types of things i
do i need to do
best thing you can do is kind of go on
this thing
on this website and
decide you know how do i want to adjust
this plot um you can just you know type
in in layman's terms and gdp with ggbot
and there's gonna be something that pops
up where you can kind of go into the
formats of these you know scale y or
stuff like that and kind of get it down
um because uh it is a little bit um very
tech it is very technical to do these
slight minor adjustments that kind of
seem almost um too hard to do
but um you can do it like
programmatically so it is very useful um
in the long term
okay
so
that's kind of a basic way of you know
plotting out and adjusting the y and x
axis with you know your general title
subtitles colors x y you know you can do
dollar percent formats um
one thing i want to do is just kind of
go back to our original data set that
we're working on
so
uh y goes
uh with
gm
point
and then we'll all do a color
both dudes species
so now we're gonna go into
um themes
um in this case uh if we add a theme
uh legend we can do
uh some different things
so the theme is basically kind of like
uh the overall kind of global aesthetics
of the ggplot object and if we look at a
theme there is a lot of things so
this is basically kind of like the fine
tuning of your plot so you can kind of
adjust the axis title uh
access title.x there's a lot of
different things and i can't go through
all of it because frankly i don't know a
lot about it but
um
one thing i would say is like that i use
when i use theme is the legend
dot position so as you can see if we
type in a legend there's so many
commands right so you can do very fine
tuning
um in this case if you're like a data
scientist or an analyst
and you're just kind of creating plots
to kind of get some type of um
to do some type of like you know
um ad hoc analysis or whatever or just
want to kind of look at some some data
this is something you wouldn't really
want to mess with you know we want to do
like a quick and dirty plot to go into
some other um
process but you know if you're like a
data journalist and you're creating a
plot to put you know in some type of
article
this is something that you'd be probably
messing with a lot we're doing these
like fine-tuned adjustments to put onto
like a magazine or a website or an
article so
that being said
when i do use theme uh often i'll use
the legend.position
um in this case you know sometimes i
don't want the position i don't want a
legend so i could say election equals
none
um
you can also specify maybe like on the
top
um so sometimes i'll change the legend
position to the top so that way i have
more real estate to actually look at it
so
um that was a pretty um long-winded
conversation just to show you how i
changed the legend but if you do want to
do a lot of fine tuning i'm definitely
looking to theme
uh the theme object and that
will get you kind of down the rabbit
hole of like you know data visualization
and stuff like that
finally um we can actually kind of look
over the actual or gt plots so with
ggplot
um
you have an object so you can also
return it you can also assign it
you can also assign it to a object so if
we assign it to p
we now can execute p and it'll pull out
out the actual plot
and we also can build upon it so plus
like
labs
title is equal to um
species
like that um and then we can assign it
again
to a new object and we'll get you know
that right there um i'm gonna go
actually into how to save a plot
um how to save a bot is one you can kind
of like
expand it
uh
i think you can like copy it sometimes
if you're in the r um
like the r terminal seven r
uh markdown
um document
uh oh yeah okay so yeah you can like
save the image right there oops that's
uh
that's a photo of me for uh linkedin uh
you can save like that
um you can also like copy the image and
paste it somewhere um maybe i can open
up a word document
so if you like you know someone asked
you to
okay
yeah so if someone like asked hey like
what are you working on you can just
like do a quick email paste it into like
a slack chat or whatever
um
but um kind of way you should be doing
it is using a gg save so gg save
um in this case you want to specify the
file name so file name equals like
first plot um in this case you can use
like a png a pdf i think a jpeg so in
this case i usually just use a png
and then you can specify the plot
um by default you can see the plot is
the last plot so we actually call in i
think the last spot
it'll call in it'll basically say like
what was the most recent plot that you
like plotted out
um so called that
so by default let's say your last plot
but you can also specify the plot object
and then
let's see what else do i want to do
and then you can have you know the path
of it where it's at by default i think
it'll use your working directory and you
can do the width height and units dpi
probably keep that 300 maybe if you want
to increase it if you like want to put
on like a magazine or uh depending on
the your printer you're gonna print it
out but
that being said it doesn't really matter
so right now i'm just gonna say you know
first plot
simple thing does it by a 7x7 inch image
i'm going to
open it
on a different screen so i don't leak
anything and then
i'll open that up
and we can
you can see we have a pot i don't know
why it's yellow that's a little odd
uh
i was messing with some uh graphics and
stuff like that so that's a little odd
but
um it shouldn't do that
it's actually weird
okay
but um something we might want to do is
like width is like you know
uh 11
you know height is 8.5 units
put in inches
and we can save that and we can get
maybe like a
bigger plot like that it's actually
really weird i don't know why it's doing
that but
um no worries
so um that's basically it for this video
um i kind of went over just overall like
you know simple plus the overall
velocity of ggplot you know the idea of
stacking layers onto it using aesthetics
ex
using the aesthetics in the g2 but
object passing it in as like almost like
a global variable and then using those
gold uh gold variables into our stacked
layers then i went over like obviously
like theming colors all the cool stuff
that makes your plots look really pretty
and finally i did a brief thing into
like how to actually save it so
um this is obviously a lot of stuff um
this video was already running into 40
minutes when i thought it was gonna be
like a 15 minute video so you can see
that there's a lot of content and stuff
like that but
um that being said like it is a lot but
it is the most important
i guess package in
maybe our r in general
um there's a lot of things you can do
with ggplot but there's even more since
there's even more now since we have like
ggplot extensions so if we go over here
to extensions we can see that there's a
lot of cool plots that
you if you now have watched this video
you're saying like how would i even make
this plot you know
or how would i make uh you know gg this
plot like what does that even look like
so i figured that i would also make a
video on some common and useful ggpot
extensions to use since i've already
created a basic video on gtpot
so i hope you guys enjoyed the video
i'll see you guys next time and tadayon